i'm kristen goodwin on this episode of
the fox news rundown
president-elect joe biden formally
introducing key members of his economic
team
to help overcome the financial fallout
brought on by the coronavirus pandemic
robert wolf former obama economic
advisor and fox news contributor
and founding editor of the washington
free beacon matthew continetti
discussed mr biden's nominees and the
upcoming senate runoffs in georgia
the assassination of iran's top nuclear
scientist
masan fakhrazadi once again setting the
middle east on
edge reigniting tensions who is
responsible
and how will this affect the
relationship between washington
and tehran dr jim walsh an expert in
international security
and a research associate at the
massachusetts institute of technology's
security studies program
joins the rundown to share his insight
plus commentary from jimmy fayla
host of fox across america the fox news
rundown is a daily news podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm jerry willis i'm steve ducey i'm
shannon breme and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday december 2nd 2020 i'm lisa
brady
the president-elect picks an economic
team that has their work cut out for
them which
could include raising taxes one in six
small businesses have closed
you have states that can't fund the
services needed
we have so many things we need to do and
i actually think
it's like a patriotic tax i'm dave
anthony
who killed iran's top nuclear scientist
there are several theories and possible
motives
assassinating him at this point
might somehow scramble the politics uh
for a new president biden entering into
office who
his uh stated goal is to re-enter
the iran nuclear deal and i'm jimmy
fella
i've got the final word on the fox news
rundown
president-elect joe biden is building
the team he says can lead the u.s
out of a pandemic-driven recession we're
going to create a recovery for everybody
for all we're going to get this economy
moving again
on tuesday formally introducing an
economic team he hopes will be led by
janet yellen
she was the first woman to be fed chief
and would be the first woman to serve
as treasury secretary out of our
collective pain
as a nation we will find collective
purpose
to control the pandemic and build our
economy back
better than before there is also a
shared message of advancing racial
equality and
diversity on the team itself economist
cecilia rouse would be the first
african-american to chair the council of
economic advisors or cea
in nera tandon the first woman of color
and south asian
american to serve as director of the
office of management and budget
i'm especially proud to work alongside
leaders who understand
that budgets are not abstractions they
are a reflection of our values
they touch our lives in profound ways
her parents are from india and tandon
talks about wanting everyone to have the
fair
chance her mom got using the safety net
of food stamps and public housing while
raising her kids alone for a time
tanden's critics are focusing on her
later years as an aide to hillary
clinton
and outspoken president of the liberal
center for american progress
with a history of political tweets
already raising concern about a senate
confirmation vote
jared bernstein who served as biden's
chief economist when he was vice
president
would also serve on the council of
economic advisors
i think thus far he's put a great
experience team together
and i put experience with a capital e
robert wolf is a former economic advisor
to president obama
ceo of 32 advisors and a fox news
contributor
i think when you look at his economic
team
and you look at his national security
team
it's clear that he wanted people who
had experience who were not new to
washington
who were not new to in some ways the
role you could almost argue when you
look at
um you know certainly uh you know former
fed chair
janet yellen and coming in as treasury
secretary
so i i i think he's really um has a a
great
cabinet and i think that he needs a
great cabinet
because we have the book ends being the
pandemic
and the the need for an economic
recovery
and both of those things are with an
incredible sense of urgency lisa
but in terms of the experience that he's
tapping into i mean there has been some
criticism that it's starting to look
kind of like a reboot
of the obama administration i mean could
that
end up turning some people off if you
look at the obama administration when
they came in
we were losing 800 000 jobs a month
and if you look at where he brought this
economic recovery to
we had a robust stock market
we had robust jobs we were averaging 225
000 private sector job gains a month
which
is a higher average than the three year
period before covert of president trump
so um as someone who is uh
is as a fan of the obama administration
i'm
all for us having some of the people
that had experience that being said
it's very different than where we were
in 2008 when the obama team came in
and were inaugurated in 09
because this is not a financial
recession
this is not based on financial banks
leverage
in the system this economic recession
was brought upon by the pandemic
republicans are raising concern about
this economic team assuming everyone
you know is confirmed and put in place
um
possibly raising taxes reimposing more
regulation
things that could stifle the rebound of
an economy that has been slammed
by the pandemic are you concerned at all
about that i mean is it the wrong
time to be raising taxes i think
a couple things one we don't know
whether tax reform
will or will not happen because it
actually starts with whether
who's running the senate if if the gop
continues to have a majority in the
senate and win
georgia then the idea of joe biden and
structural tax reform
is highly unlikely that being said
i think there's a need for tax reform
lisa after every war
um literally since 1776
the country has followed with taxes to
pay for the war
this pandemic is a war how are we going
to pay for all the things that we need
to do
one in six small businesses have closed
you have states that can't fund the
services needed
we have so many things we need to do and
i
actually think it's like a patriotic tax
the wealthiest people in the country who
have benefited the most okay are gonna
have to give a little more
and as one of those i'm okay with that
what about
the possibility of personalities
getting in the way or distracting from
the agenda and i ask
that with the potential budget chief
nira tandon
in mind because she's been getting some
early pushback
from both sides of the aisle why is she
such a lightning rod
and does she deserve that bipartisan
criticism
i think that a couple things during the
uh hillary clinton bernie race that took
place
in 2015 and 16 she was a passionate
clinton supporter
and she you know was very
outspoken in defending hillary versus
bernie
and making sure people knew the
differences so yeah there are some
people on i would say the populist left
that
have issues with maybe how nera
handled that during that situation but
that's politics i mean
you know politics at times have sharp
elbows and you need to get the puck out
of the corner
i think with respect to how she um
handled some senate republicans that are
upset about
twitter i mean honestly if we're not
gonna
confirm someone because you know they
were called
you know lazy someone or a lying someone
on twitter versus what this president
has said on twitter
i mean you've got to be kidding me the
media gets accused by republicans at
least of fawning
over the president-elect you could use
as a case in point his
all-female communications team when
president trump had a lot of women in
those
roles as well is this a honeymoon for
biden
is he going to face even a fraction of
the same
scrutiny going forward that president
trump did well i don't think i mean i'm
a fox contributor you're on fox i don't
think fox is giving him a free pass so
you know in my opinion uh the media i'd
like to think
is going to be constructively
challenging
uh president-elect on his cabinet picks
on his policies
and i guarantee president-elect won't
call them the enemy of the state
he won't lie 20 000 times in a
three-year period
so i i feel pretty good that the
relationship
is going to be constructively
challenging but one of respect
which this administration didn't handle
that way at all
republicans however are expecting a
double standard from the media
of course yeah well i mean all the
stories we've been seeing about
joe biden's pets matthew continetti is
founding editor of the free beacon
stories about you know where where he'll
be eating out
um the celebrations of the all-female
media team you know we've just had a
female uh probably still have a female
press expert right now
and um mac and nanny and we had one
before her
uh two before her actually grizzly and
huckabee
um so uh yeah the the double standard
will be will be there
um but it you know it hasn't stopped uh
republican victories
um in the past and i i don't expect it
to stop it now
um the real the real question is uh will
republicans find a way to shoot
themselves in the foot
which they also have had a tendency to
do in the past
the overriding question is whether the
biden team will be able to build back
better
or at least better than the obama
recovery from the financial crisis which
republicans criticize
as the slowest since the great
depression well a lot depends on what
these
uh new choices uh providence economic
team
do once they find themselves in power
next year
certainly the markets liked the
announcement that janet yellen
would be biden's nominee for the
secretary of the treasury
and i think the general response marcus
has been positive
because she's seen as a steady hand
someone who obviously has a long
resume but once
the administration comes into office
they're going to have to face
uh real choices about the level of taxes
spending and regulation
they they want to impose on the country
and
if they grow government too big if they
restrict economic activity through
lockdowns for example or if they
uh repeal the entirety of the trump tax
cut which they have promised to do
there could be negative economic
consequences i know one of the arguments
that's made
frequently is that well if biden raises
taxes
it's not going to hit people under 400
000 and they seem to
not draw the parallel between not
raising taxes on those under a certain
income but repealing
the trump tax cuts and i guess it's
because they always say that those tax
cuts benefited mainly the wealthy
so how do you sort of get those
those arguments in line if you will well
i i think
a lot of nonpartisan studies have shown
that everybody received uh benefit from
the trump tax cut as probably the
larger benefits went to people with
larger incomes of course they pay
more in taxes so it makes sense that
they would get a bigger boost
nonetheless you know i think the the
problem for the biden administration is
they'd be coming into office at a time
when most americans had a generally
positive view of the trump economy and
whether that was through the tax cut
which was really his signature domestic
uh accomplishment or whether that was
through just
pausing the regulation and also getting
rid of some of the more onerous
regulations that barack obama
announced in the last year of his
presidency
whether that was through restricting
immigration to be honest there's some
data which suggests that if you restrict
low-skilled immigration then that's
going to push up wages among
low low wage workers and and the thing
about the trump boom
is that it helped everybody
unlike say the obama recovery where most
of the gains went
to uh people who were already well off
what how much of an impact could biden's
early picks
his early steps that he's made so far um
have on those upcoming senate races in
georgia
well i i actually think what's happening
on capitol hill
in terms of covet relief is going to
have a much
bigger impact on the special elections
in the
in georgia but i think more important
will be
the issue of not only the virus of
relief
for the virus but also the idea of you
know who do you want to control the
united states the senate do you want to
allow the democrats to have basically
control with vice president-elect
harris's tie-breaking vote
um that would free them up to do a lot
of things including possibly
eliminating the filibuster um and
changing the rules of the game to help
to help them and to help
liberal priorities or or not matthew
continetti founding editor of the free
beacon
thank you so much for your time thank
you
[Music]
this is jimmy fella with your fox news
commentary coming up
it's a whodunit the assassination of
iran's
top nuclear scientist months after a top
general was killed in a u.s
drone strike if you're working at the
higher reaches of the iranian
governments
or their military or their terrorist
organization the revolutionary guard
corps i
think you probably don't want to be
walking under any ladders anytime soon
republican senator tom cotton now unlike
the january attack in iraq that took out
general qasim soleimani who
the u.s called a terrorist no one is
taking credit for killing
mohsin fakhrazada last week
now he is considered the father of
iran's nuclear program
iran blames israel and suggests saudi
arabia and the u.s may be involved in a
conspiracy
and is vowing revenge a concern to
democratic congressman john garamendi
who told fox
my guess is it will be something that
will be pinpointed it might very well be
in the diplomatic area
not in the military area so what does
this all mean for
iran's nuclear program well i think it
means
different things at different levels
jim walsh is a middle east and nuclear
expert
senior research associate at mit's
security studies program
iran had a active nuclear weapons
program beginning in the late 1990s
uh and then was halted in 2003
so mike and then they built the civilian
nuclear establishment around that and so
taking out one person might not be as
important
in a big organization as it would be in
a smaller organization but you know it
all depends on who replaces them so i
think it's an open question
as to what impact it will have on the
program itself but i think most experts
will
imagine that it'll just more or less
continue you know as it is
all right what about the next level then
yeah yeah yeah the next level then is
the political level there is the notion
that
doing this uh assassinating uh
him at this point might somehow scramble
the politics
uh for a new president biden entering
into office who
his uh stated goal is to re-enter
the iran nuclear deal the agreement that
president trump had withdrawn and his
plan is to
re-enter and there's some thinking that
at a political level the impact might be
to make rejoining that more complicated
the iranians will be bad and not want to
play ball or that there would be other
consequences
okay now that if that's the case if that
is a goal
behind this there have been some people
claiming that the u.s had to be involved
that the trump administration would have
to be involved i mean there was
this report in november that that
president trump had to be talked out of
trying to take military action against
iran so
where do you stand on that you know i'm
i
in the absence of any facts i i'm pretty
open-minded here so
it seems to me perfectly plausible that
israel by themselves
and without notification would have
carried it out on their own the reason i
say that is
that it's well established that four
decades going back even to the 1960s
israeli intelligence has assassinated
weapon scientists in other countries
from egypt to iraq and
iran as well so you know israel seems
like a pretty good bet but they may have
told the u.s
or they might not have told the u.s i'm
open on that and it's also conceivable
that the president asked israel to carry
out this operation
uh that he wanted to take if he wasn't
going to be able to use airstrikes or
some other method
one to to impose pressure or cost on
iran
and thought that israel israel doing it
might be a better way to go about it i i
think that's a possibility
i i doubt that the u.s would have been
directly
you know operationally involved but
again
you know these things are hard to know
when it's all behind closed doors
let's go into the iran nuclear program
as it is now after the us pulled out of
that international deal
there was movement for iran
to reach parts of that deal correct
its initial reaction was to just lay low
and be quiet and try to write this thing
out uh
and the president uh increasingly
pursued
what he called the maximum pressure
policy which means you know sanction
after sanction
uh punishment after punishment so after
a while
you know iran uh found a new strategy
which was it was going to start to push
back and respond
what they did was sort of selectively
break
some of their commitments so they
produced more enriched
low enriched uranium than they were
supposed to and they did
you know they had more have water than
they agreed to so at the margins
they started to take steps to sort of
signal that hey
cut this out or we're going to really
fully restart the program
okay back up one second for one second
uh for people who
i mean not a you have a great knowledge
of
what it takes to build a nuclear weapon
most of us do not so when you talk about
uranium enrichment what exactly is that
you cannot make a nuclear weapon from
low enriched uranium
really what you use low enriched uranium
for is a fuel for a nuclear power plant
to produce nuclear energy and
electricity to make a bomb you need
a uranium that's enriched not to three
or five percent but
closer to 80 or 90 and
the same box that produces three percent
enriched fuel is the same
box or centrifuge that would produce the
bomb fuel if you just kept enriching
enriching enriching enriching
so what they have right now they cannot
make you know they
they cannot make a bomb with what they
have they'd have to take what they have
now and then re-enrich it
to a higher level and they'd have to
kick out all the inspectors and then
they'd have to
you know reach in up uh some sort of
manufacturing process and so we're some
distance from that in basic terms
yes they have more material than they
did
at the beginning of the agreement but
it's actually that amount is actually
less
than they had uh before the agreement
started
in other words they had a bunch of stuff
then they entered the agreement
then they cut it all down and they let
it grow a little but they're still
they're still um they still have less
than they did prior to
the joint comprehensive plan of action
so that's where we're at now
my own guess based on talking to iranian
officials which i do frequently
and and to others in the region for all
those
noise and drama my guess is that uh iran
would rejoin
the nuclear agreement and go back into
full compliance
you know and clean up this other sort of
stuff at the margins
okay it would go back into full
complaints if if we do but
the clock is ticking here it's there's
not going to be a lot of time to do that
but i sense that's where both parties
are at right now
back to that 2015 international nuclear
deal
president obama said then we have
achieved a detailed arrangement
that permanently prohibits iran from
obtaining a nuclear weapon
it cuts off all of iran's pathways to
obama
three years later president trump pulled
the u.s out calling it a horrible deal
not only does the deal fail to halt
iran's nuclear ambitions
but it also fails to address the
regime's development
of ballistic missiles that could deliver
nuclear warheads but jim walsh still
thinks it's a good agreement
no agreement is ever perfect but this
agreement was the strongest
ever non-proliferation multilateral
which means to say lots of different
countries together in one agreement
rather than like two countries it's the
strongest multilateral non-proliferation
agreement ever negotiated i mean
iran is the most inspected country in
the world no
country has the level of intrusive
inspection
electronic monitoring inspector visits
reporting that iran does and and
by the way iran because of who it is and
the bad things it's done
no it is the most watched country in the
world the u.s intelligence community
the israeli intelligence community the
saudi the russians
everyone has eyes on iran
that said is it true that there are
still some sites they don't let
inspectors into
oh sure because no country is going to
listen an
arms a we wouldn't we don't let people
just
show up at the pentagon or at secrets
military sites in the us and let
international inspectors and if we did
that everyone would stream bloody murder
uh there the iaea has a right to inspect
any facility military or not
if it has reason to suspect that there's
a violation and it has inspected
military facilities
and it has gotten to where it wants to
go
it's still now there's one issue left
over from about two years ago where they
found contaminated particles
at a facility where there should not
have been contaminated particles and
they're still
arguing about that but in the main the
agency does not report problems with
access
and there's no intelligence
community in any country but obviously
most importantly
there's no u.s intelligence view that
iran has cheated or restarted its
nuclear weapons program
okay just just not the case but the
again part of the criticism is that the
deal doesn't prevent it
in fact it would allow it within 15
years that the idea was it would delay
iran
is that true no it's not true now
the opening paragraph of the agreement
says iran
commits not to acquiring nuclear weapons
and it is under
its nuclear non-proliferation treaty
obligations which are
in perpetuity forever some of the
regulations do come off
it at a 10-year mark at a 15-year mark
and then some of the regulations and
restrictions apply forever
it in no way allows iran to pursue a
nuclear weapon iran
under this agreement and the the uh you
know other obligations it's already
taken on
is that it would be completely illegal
for it to pursue
or try to get a nuclear weapon now if
they do that the question is how to
catch them
and that's why having people on the
ground doing inspections
is better than not having an agreement
where people aren't
on the ground and doing inspections okay
now let's get to president-elect biden
and as you talked about his plan
to re-enter that deal if he can
once he takes office you say you talk to
these
iranian officials do they want that are
they pushing for that even
with this assassination do they still
want that that's a great question dave
and you know what
they're uh a deeply divided society like
we're a deeply divided society i mean
obviously
there are a lot of differences here but
they've got uh
reformists and hardliners and clerics
and they're all fighting each other
sometimes these are fights over
ideology sometimes their fights over you
know
plain old political power but here's the
deal rouhani their president is the guy
who negotiated the agreement
he's only in office for another six
months because they have an election
coming this summer
he would like to get back into the
agreement that he signed and leave
office with some sort of
sense of accomplishment and legitimacy
and also to get some sanctions relief
but his political opponents in the
revolutionary guard hardliners in their
legislature
they of course have hopped all over this
assassination are
you know uh they are not as enthusiastic
about
rejoining the deal because they see it
as in their political interests
with an election coming up to take a
harder line so that's what we're looking
at right now
so it's uncertain and if iran retaliates
the us
may not be able to get back in right now
exactly exactly
my own sense is iran won't do that and i
thought there was a clue
and one of their recent statements after
the assassination they said
they will retaliate at the appropriate
time
or language to that effect and that i
think tells me
that they realize that they
go and retaliate tomorrow that's going
to make
you know everything complicated if not
impossible going forward so my guess is
they will retaliate but it's
they'll take their time doing it
certainly a lot of
uncertainty jim walsh thank you very
much senior research associate mit
security studies program we appreciate
you joining us on the podcast
thanks dave it was great
new from the fox news podcasts network
my name is kennedy and welcome to
my podcast which will i humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome
it's kennedy saves the world subscribe
and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
jimmy fallon
what's on your mind so joe and joe biden
are expected to get a cat in the white
house to go along with their german
shepherds major
in scout they're naming the cat
whatchamacallit so joe always calls it
by the right name which is not true the
reason this is making news is because
donald trump was the first president in
a generation who didn't have any pets in
the white house the obamas had dogs the
bushes had dogs and bill clinton had a
dog
and a cat as well as hillary's dog which
never spoke without charging you a
speaking fee but back to the bidens who
got a hundred syrupy sweet write-ups
this weekend about a cat they don't even
own yet the cat coverage is a far cry
from the relentless attacks the media
waged against donald trump on his
way into the white house think about it
when trump was president-elect the media
chased russian collusion stories like a
laser pointer they ran one anonymously
source bombshell after another with no
regard for whether or not it was true
and to be clear
i've got nothing against joe biden
getting a cat but if the media wants to
maintain
any pretense of objectivity they should
ask biden some tough questions too
and if they can't do that they should
hit the pause button on the cat stories
check out fox news radio with jimmy
fellow weekdays from noon to three
on fox news radio and foxnewsradio.com
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
fox news radio on demand on the fox news
app download the app and just click
listen
when you swipe left you can listen to
your favorite fox news talk shows live
swipe right for the latest fox news
radio newscasts on demand fox news radio
and the fox news app
download it today love fox news click
the subscribe button to get more of the
news and opinion you trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes